speaking of John Kerry so he was
speaking to the Senate Foreign Relations
Committee yesterday explaining why we
have to go to war and he made a minor
gasps would you tell us whether you
believe that a prohibition for having
American boots on the ground is that's
something that the administration would
accept as part of a resolute miss
chairman it would be preferable not to
not because the there's any intention or
any plan or any desire whatsoever to
have boots on the ground and I think the
president will give you every assurance
in the world as mi as the secretary
fence and determined but in the event
Syria imploded for instance or in the
event there was a threat of a chemical
weapons cache falling into the hands of
al-nusrah or someone else and it was
clearly in the interests of our allies
and and all of us the British the French
and others to prevent those weapons of
mass destruction falling into the hands
of the worst elements I don't want to
take off the table an option that might
or might not be available during
President United States to secure our
country so he clearly accidentally told
the truth that is the truth they can't
guarantee if something goes down that we
might have to put troops on the ground
he later said that it was a hypothetical
question and he was thinking out loud
I'm for you know generally you should
think in your head and speak out loud
but you know he's a big thing there okay
so is that the next step is what you're
saying is that we start this thing and
even if it's just about bombing some
empty buildings we don't know what's
going to happen Syria could attack
turkey they could attack Israel then
they have to respond and then yadda
yadda yadda I water is a possibility
that things don't go well can you
imagine yeah I mean mate gosh I mean
what do you make been about John's about
Kerry's just compose thats a complete
and utter gap right like didn't they
found it into his head whatever you do
don't say pajama set it right at the
percent complete another gaff but it's
true so I like it I'm glad he said it
because of course it's true it's also
true if we don't Bob yeah the fact is
the bombing may make the chemical I
don't know whether the chemical weapons
stash or more or less likely to get into
the hands of so we have to consider you
know as what we didn't do Iraq very
clearly a nice got back entire ride Film
Festival I saw uh Errol Morris's
documentary but with Don Rumsfeld known
unknown really arts either the known
unknown or the known unknown no no no no
right but he had and what we didn't do
was look past stage two we're like I
will win we they'll throw roses on our
feet and then we'll just get out the
table set up a bunch of permanent basis
will take their oil great what could go
wrong so what would carry same could
happen now and could Syria could the
wrong weapons fall in the wrong hands or
stay in Assad has any attacks that
turkey or Israel is brought in some way
if somebody else get of course that
could happen and then we're then we're
gonna put boots on the ground right yeah
so it's a final thought of this do you
guys see this as inevitable as we sit
here right now are we absolutely going
toward in two weeks from now that's also
essentially would carry was saying was
so interesting it was like well if with
Congress decides not to support the
president's plan then what happened was
essentially saying well you know that
you're gonna it's gonna happen so does
Obama look like the biggest schmuck ever
if we don't go to war because now
they've laid out the case so if cop if
Congress votes no doesn't Obama have to
do it anyway just for that same hubris
that you were making fun of though or
who's you look like a schmuck to to the
army guys I think they care about what
the army guys I do but I mean so look
like a schmuck I mean look if it's wrong
I don't and and maybe not you know and
and you know the uh you know the you
know the soldier who chooses not to
fight is arguably the bravest soldier of
the mall to totally bastardized Bob
Dylan's line and restrictions adaptation
of it but uh so I don't know I mean look
if it's the right thing to do if you if
there's a plan that could really hurt
Assad with the 41 days of precision
bombing yeah then I don't know that it's
the worst thing in the world are I I
think that you'd probably turn a lot of
the country around but nobody quite
believes that that plan is even possibly
in existence right that's the problem
yeah all right well obviously the story
is gonna keep unfolding stay
rest with Nancy Pelosi's grandson and
also i was watching CNN yesterday and
Wolf Blitzer asked one of the guests why
haven't the Americans cared about this
for two years and maybe wolf it's
because you guys have completely ignored
okay